good morning bachelor nation what a
treat
thank you for turning tuning into roses
and rose a live here on et live and I am
here live with Leo d'ottavio round of
applause for Leo in our little studio
here yes Leo I have not gotten to meet
you this season I have just been
watching you and your luscious locks
through my screen so it's lovely to see
them here in person and you guys his
hair smells great how often do you wash
that hair not often not often that's the
key there's a lot of chlorine in the
show I do so I think that's how it oh
because you really aren't your stuntman
you do a multiple times a week you
perform a show at Universal here in LA
yeah yeah it's a good it's a good time
and keeps me busy and it's really fun
during the summer it's a fun job and
he's been getting a lot of questions
from bachelorette fans now who attend
the show absolutely not okay so of
course I'm sure you guys have questions
and comments for Leo especially because
we are hot off of men tell all
so Leo's gonna tell all and he will
answer your questions leave them on our
social platforms that will get them here
on the iPad and we are going to dive
right in okay Leo I do want to get to
mental all but first I have to address a
few just like things about you this
season one how often do people tell you
you look like Jason Momoa that that's a
common occurrence recently I think you
know he's been very popular the last
couple years of the Aquaman and all that
yeah yeah I get that a lot
yeah I'm not Hawaiian like he is but you
know I think there's a job for future
for you beat like actually being his
stunt double oh yeah I'm sure they put
some wigs on guys you know but yeah
we're about the same size you know I
would be a great job I'd do it there we
go he would do it too
not at mental I'll missing from mental
was clay Harbor we got to see a
wonderful moment in the bloopers of you
and clay and a bathtub together highly
iconic where was clay what can you tell
us clay was trying to win a his his way
back into the NFL you know he's really
working hard on doing that right now so
I you know it instead of coming and
hearing us all like whine I think it was
a good idea for him to just focus on his
football career you know there's a
there's a little money involved there
you know hey
Bank clay was such a good guy he seems
like a guy who was such a hard worker
and just like good to everybody in the
house I would I would say that's a great
way to describe clay he was probably why
we got really really close in the
especially in the bathtub that was a
great time but uh yeah he was a he's a
kind sois a gentle giant you know he
he's you think let go guys in the NFL
they're gonna be like you know a certain
way but when you met him he was really
humble and he was really now he takes
care of his whole family the guys
he's a kind individual I hope to to be
his friend for a long time oh good soul
who are you closest with out of the guys
here he's staying tight we're definitely
a Colton clay Jason Blake all the top
guys Will's you know he's in LA Kristin
he's in LA so we've been hanging out to
you sometimes and in Knicks bets kiss is
a guy that was really hilarious yeah we
had a lot of humorous fun we had a lot
of banter that was uh there was behind
the scenes and you know during the
filming it was really fun yeah he's a
character were you guys surprised to see
some of the night one guys there as
Chris Harrison went around the room
those first few guys I think Camille I
was like who who are you
did you remember them yeah that's why I
asked asked one of them I was I said
excuse me sir what's your name when they
started talking but yeah the night one
guys were surprising you to be there but
you know they add a little flair you got
to you got to see what they want to say
to you it's it's it's interesting I may
had a few things to say that one man it
was cropped pants there were a lot of
looks being worked you had on like what
color it was kind of a deep red burgundy
suit lovely everybody was really serving
the fashion at the men told your I was
trying to be slightly humorous with it I
think it was Colton stylist and I asked
her to make me look like Ron Burgundy as
much as possible
I love it that's so like Colton as a
stylist you're friends with cold and
it's like you know exactly exactly
he's a kind gentleman he's a kind guy
help everybody I well we're gonna get
into that because I do want your take on
it
Sofia on youtube says can you tell us
any funny moments from the mansion that
they didn't show on the show anything
any story you wish had made it to TV
yeah you know they had a nice little uh
we had a mock trial
in Utah where I played John Blanc and
then Knicks bet
Spets guess was who's a lawyer was kind
of running the court and there was a
judge I think Jason was the judge and
Nick was defending me as far as my
actions after you know like what he did
in Utah so uh that was pretty hilarious
good let's get a second chance for Nick
I have to say watching him I was like oh
that guy is cute I didn't notice it
before and a lawyer Nick in paradise
okay back had some good guys a lot of
guys with legit careers hard workers I
mean things got patty at times but
overall a good group of guys except for
one Lincoln he wasn't there if you guys
want to know Chris Harrison's take on
why that is up at et online.com
and I'm glad Sofia brought up funny
moments because I had almost forgotten
about how you were the one just calling
Lincoln out with your eyes when he was
saying the earth was flat yeah but was
it wild to you to then hear that he had
this criminal background did you guys
have any sense of that in the house
mm-hmm
you know I don't I don't think we really
thought that anybody didn't pass a
background test or whatever but it was
you know I don't really know details
about what it is or what happened I
never really I don't read too much into
any of that stuff but no we you trust
that the process and everybody that's
there is there for the right reasons at
least you have to go in with that
attitude with it so no we didn't really
have a sense of that you know I mean I
personally wouldn't hang out with the
guy but that's all I really well he
thought the earth was flat I have one
more this is just like such a silly
thing but it's been kind of circulating
this season there's a rumor that you
were in a certain type of movie hmm a
certain softcore type of film oh yeah
softcore I mean if you yeah if we want
to call any section you know film
softcore then sure it was it was a sex
scene in a movie I am an actor and a
stuntman and I've been doing a Vanunu
for a while but yeah that's it was a sex
scene in a movie but I loved that the
tabloids want to call it a porn but yeah
but I don't think ABC would be okay with
a with a guy with a porn background I
mean thank you for clearing it up
the thing I kind of did a little bit of
my you know journalistic work and looked
it up and I thought not that I entirely
know the definition or the specific
parameters but it just seemed like a
movie so the sex scene for a movie sexy
I mean the stuff of that Jason Momoa did
on Game of Thrones is definitely a lot
worse than anything I did but but yeah
but anybody that checks it out it's you
know it's it's entertaining it was
pretty funny it was a humorous high-heel
homicide yes leo d'ottavio okay you guys
well we have enjoyed that what was it I
got enjoy life it was fun I mean you
seem like a guy who you are so playful
like follow Leo on Instagram you're so
fun to watch and overall enjoyed your
experience on the show yeah I would say
it was a very enjoyable experience I
mean besides the lack of sleep I think
that's the only thing you really don't
sleep you're just on the go
yeah you're on the go but also you know
that we were sleeping with you know
there's a lot guys moving around the
house and stuff falling out of beds you
know and things of that nature so yeah
you know the lack of sleep is pretty
evident so you start getting a little
delirious without the alcohol or
anything David was on mental all I mean
when he fell out of that bed like could
you really hear it in the house was it
kind of a crazy night yeah it was it was
a crazy night I I was so tired I didn't
even get out of bed to look at the
commotion I was like Erica via youtube
quote what hair products do you use this
is important what is your your hair
routine Leah you know I was I tried to
tell people that I'm trying to come up
with a hair routines I don't really have
a hair routine so I'm trying to there's
products being sent to me you know some
companies want to like me to try out
their products so I'm trying them out
I'll let everybody know which ones I
think are great you know what do you
stand by you only wash a few times a
week yeah I would say sulfate free
shampoo and conditioner just you know
don't don't let it dry it out too much I
mean I kind of have naturally curly hair
people ask I don't I don't do too much
do it but yeah like I'm in the you know
I mean the Waterworld show has a lot of
chlorine in the water it's like being a
swimmer you know
I'm in there all the time so I don't
know if the chlorine is being maybe it's
it's adding its maybe it's good for my
hair I don't know he's investigating the
exploring I think that we need to see
you do the covers of romance novels have
you ever posed for one of those no I've
never posed for one of those but a a guy
on the season actually did Trent he was
there shortly but he was he actually has
done romance novel covers which i think
is hilarious because i what a spectrum
of careers right okay so we have more of
you guys as questions coming in thank
you so much we're gonna get to these I
want to dive into mental I'll of course
we brought up Colton first let's play
this sound this little clip that we have
between Colton and Jean Blanc because
people really came for Colton about his
virginity reveal and Jean Blanc had a
very vile thing to say here it is okay
I'll take it back in three seconds
[Applause]
[Music]
now we're here that mean Colton you
acting like a but you never been so I
don't know what's going
[Applause]
not classy not classy San Diego
I mean your face and that what I have to
say leo that I loved is when I was
watching you weren't really laughing at
that I mean what was your reaction in
the moment reaction of the moment was
like why is this guy even getting a
chance to talk really I don't know Jean
Blanc seemed he's one of those guys that
uh seemed to be a little bit
opportunistic yeah I would say like even
even when he gave her the gift at the
end like it's like clearly you're trying
to sell some more perfume so you know
when you come off that like ridiculous
how dishonest or whatever it's just
point like Colton's virginity isn't
something that's that should be a
negative especially in today's society I
think that we need more of it to be
honest so I think that the fact that
John Blanc was was being you know really
trashy with the way he came at : there
is a witty witty way to kind of address
anything or to clap back at someone but
that was just like kind of hidden below
the belt okay got the cold no but got
the colton a little bit not you know it
was nice to see jeez I mean I'm pretty
like Colin's the kind of guy like he he
like puts like in like he puts
everything aside like at some point so
I'm sure his differences with jean blanc
weren't gonna like last long time he was
really just kind of upset that you know
he really made Becca's time a lot more
difficult on the show that's for sure
you know yeah so when you guys I know
there's always and we see on social
media you guys go out after have fun
together you're all reunited anybody who
wasn't there I mean after what Jon Blunk
did and said is he out with the group or
who wasn't present you know what he
isn't around any of the guys so I don't
think it even needs to really be
addressed as far as is he out with the
group I don't I don't think anybody's
gonna be reaching out to okay so he was
not partying with you guys anybody else
he wasn't there no I think everyone we
we all party together okay by Jean Blanc
I don't have time for it okay so more
comments coming in Pierce wants to know
you know appear something to save your
question because we're gonna get to this
you were again talking about how it kind
of got to colton a little bit was that
hard as his friend to see him up there
in tears I mean it felt
I saw looks on Colton's face during
mental all that I had not seen all
season like I felt like I saw real
frustration and then he got up there and
he was in tears and I don't think we'd
seen him cry all season really did you
see a different side of him come at a
mental you know yeah he he's a sensitive
person you know he he has a lot of
kindness he wants to give back a lot in
you you can tell that he's you know he's
had his demons you know and and for
someone he's probably had to deal with
those kind of comments before especially
you know in the locker room and things
like that so he it probably brought him
back to a place that he didn't want to
go to and I was you know a very negative
kind of place in his life where he had
to like lie about who he was and now
that he opened up about who he truly is
in front of like millions of people I
think that he wants to build off that
and go in a direction that's more you
know positive he doesn't want to like go
back to to have to love having to lie
about who he is and such yeah so yeah it
was it was tough to see him like that
you know and I didn't like it I actually
I defended him on it that was a didn't
play it but I just said like we need
more of him out there like not all the
great comments may care but yeah it was
a it was it was vulnerable of him to
open up the way that he did and I talked
to Colton about that by the way guys at
ETA online calm is our full interview
with Colton from after mentos all he
talks about revealing the virginity
things like people he had lied to about
it before to teammates and coaches and
just the whole experience for him and
also addresses how people have been
questioning his motives and going on The
Bachelorette so check that out what do
you think of that you've made a little
chuckle there yeah I think he had good
motives yeah yeah I don't think that I
knew that's legitimate he he really fell
for Becca was there anybody who didn't
fall for Becca here's the thing she's
beautiful she is Winley such a good
person I've interviewed her several
times at this point been through so much
in her life a lot of the guys on your
season seem to have fallen really hard
and I think it's because like what's not
to like I mean did you get that sense
that everyone had really really true
feelings for her yes I would say
absolutely I mean that's why Chris
Harrison was like does anybody have
anything bad
no no one really had anything yeah she's
a truly unique individual you know
Minnesota nice nice a nice little
compliment coming in for you from ELISA
on YouTube she says Leo you never
brought drama in the house you always
conducted yourself with such class and
integrity true story you were always
there to like bring a little light
heartedness but also rise above the fray
you were just such a welcome presence I
do want to talk about Jordan who made
quite a few comments at Metin tell all
comments that I didn't always understand
let's play this little moment actually
between you and Jordan here's a clip
from last night's episode Jordan you're
your modern-day narcissus you fell in
love with yourself they're constantly
gonna be questioning me for the next 10
years how did this guy even exist
I've got billboards up in all their
minds for paving highways so much in so
little time he should have worn a work
bus they've got he's got billboards up
on pavement Highway is he your the
elephant or the mouse maybe the other
way around like I don't know where he
comes up with this stuff do you think he
pre writes it and goes in with some
stuff and behind no you know what it is
it's funny being somebody like in the
industry you know you take like an
improv class or something and it kind of
teaches you like loosen up and yes and
right like Jordan's kind of a naturally
pretty good improv er the guy can really
yes and yes and yes hands himself
exactly it's almost like he's talking to
somebody it's it comes from such a like
a goofy place it's like not like I kind
of felt like he was really not too much
of a competition it with like Beca with
like he he was like entertaining to her
but like you never really felt like you
know you looked at her with Blake or
like you know Garrett or like Colton or
Jason or even wills like and you you see
like a connection but what Jordan it was
like alright well you know I keep him
around as as much as you want like I was
like keep him in the house you know he
was like just an entertaining goofy
little dude I mean it wasn't like a he
was never like he never really truly
brought any anger out in me like he did
with David like I didn't get that you
know well and I also have to say Jordan
as he said many times last night
I mean I hope no one was playing a
drinking game where they were drinking
every time Jordan says he is himself and
has always been himself but he is and he
didn't really come at people with like I
wouldn't call him a villain he wasn't
coming at people with anger and trying
to create problems he was defending
himself and saying ridiculous things
that were wonderful to hear but you
called him a modern-day narcissus yeah I
guess we end on that a little bit do you
think Jordans a narcissist yeah I mean
Jordan really truly truly saw his
reflection once and fell in love forever
which is great I mean you know what he
speaking beginning of a lifelong romance
you know so go for it I there is a level
of a certain narcissism you need to have
to want to be on a show like The
Bachelorette and to enjoy it you know
and he really enjoys it we're all a
little narcissistic you know and I'm in
but in a healthy way I think there's a
level of healthy narcissism that that
needs to be had to want to do this but
but Jordan he truly likes it and I think
he took the comment like I think he
liked it he liked hearing you know he
won't tell you that but he liked hearing
that he's a modern-day narcissus you
know like I think that yeah I think
narcissus first look at his reflection
like you know and I think it was at a
river or like a lake well and Colton and
Jordan all said a little bit of back and
forth but again when you guys go out
after like it is everybody cool with
Jordan at all good Jordan is like the
he's the guy that like talks to the club
owner right before everybody comes in I
just go how you doing yeah the beguine
Colombier go ahead and it's like the
next thing we know we're in there with
some bottle service you know well that's
a great friend to have oh it's a great
friend and and Nick and Nikki and Jordan
together oh just a hoot the guys yeah I
mean I'm all about humor I mean I don't
think we have much else in life but a
little laughter and those two guys can
make me laugh and they're hilarious okay
Jordan doesn't even you know like
everybody parties but Jordan wasn't even
drinking much when I when I was hanging
out with him tries to keep his wits
about him he just kind of he's just a
character well he has so many Wits to
play an alien who knows I
mean I so do you think with Jordan you
said he has all this confidence in
himself some people though that is to
cover up an insecurity do you think
that's what it is with Jordan or is he
just truly he loves himself which is
great I think he gets up every morning
and really is happy that he is Jordan
great I can't wait to watch my Faraday
did you guys get closer I'm paradise
yeah absolutely okay cool and also with
we were just talking you know when I
forgot was that we're gonna get back to
it oh you were talking about how he
wasn't really drinking or anything well
who was like the biggest partyer then
who's the biggest part of God all the
guys are do you live like everybody you
drink man all those guys can drink a
little bit so yeah I would say they're
all pretty evenly party animals did you
need to let loose a little bit after
that man yes absolutely I think
everybody wanted okay more comments
coming in for you is the Beth from
YouTube says Leah what are your chances
of being the next Bachelor she wants to
see it happen that's really sweet
I think the chances of me being the next
Bachelor are about as much as having a
colony on Mars in the next year I'd say
they're equal chances why is that I just
don't think I'm clean-cut enough and I
don't know I've said this before but I
don't know like a lot of the bachelors
like you know they uh they usually have
like like more steady jobs than mine you
know little careers like exciting it's
exciting yeah you know like a yeah like
you know what I live lived out here in
LA for a long time so not it's not cheap
you know I figured out a way to do it so
it's uh it's interesting but so are you
single right now I yes
okay guys hit him up slide into the DMS
I'm giving you the opportunity have you
had a couple messages I've had a couple
me yeah there's been very very sweet
keep them coming back also want to talk
about you mentioned Becca's top guys
Jason so Jason on men tell all
man we saw him tear up as well um he
debuted a new haircut which by the way I
asked him about so head over to et
online.com and check out that perhaps
the most important interview I've ever
done
finding out what Jason's new hair
routine is we're talking to Leo about
hair Jason about hair this is the stuff
that matters you guys so I really
thought Jason he was someone I grew to
like all season long and I really like
you know you're watching and always
funny oh I didn't realize he's funny and
he's always this good guy you know now
he's getting more emotional and then it
mental all I gotta say Jason really
checked a lot of boxes on the Jason for
Bachelor Train I mean he cried he was so
sweet to Becca he wanted to make sure he
was friends with her he was calling
people out in a very adult way what did
you think of Jason's mental moments I
thought that he he must have trained for
weeks for it but he did great now I'm
just kidding he's he's always been like
that
he's a poised guy you know he's a guy
that has a very difficult job it's it's
a lot of responsibility he he's a pro
and he would be a good bachelor
absolutely you know he he knows how to
let loose and I saw all different sides
of him cuz the first couple weeks like
in the mansion like he had and he didn't
get a group date and he hadn't had a lot
of time with Becca and he was vulnerable
and and we would have these nighttime
chats you know or we'd like kind of help
each other feel good and he was like my
bunk buddy up he was on the top bunk so
we we grew really close you know and as
the season progressed you know he he
developed a relationship with Becca that
was beautiful and but we all saw it
coming like it you know we we could tell
vit that he was gonna bond with her like
Dean they seem like a good match you
know and I think that he would make a
great bachelor but I think a lot of guys
would okay I love a bunk buddy nighttime
chat love the bonding well then let's
talk about I mean of course we do not
want to reveal anything and the
Bachelorette finale is next week you
guys but if we're looking at the top
couple of guys without knowing anything
about what has happened but say Blake
Garrett and Jason are in the mix do you
have a pick somebody you'd really like
to see become the bachelor see if I do I
have a pic no any of those guys would be
great you guys Garrett I'm close with
Kari yeah what did you and Blake in in
Jason okay so all of them I'm excited to
hear Garrett to give an interview for
the first time you know he had that like
Instagram scandal moment but we haven't
heard from him much more since then so
excited to talk to Garrett more what do
you think did people
Jim too harshly do you know different
Garrett I know the Garrett that that I
you know spending time with someone
literally 24 hours a day for seven weeks
that's about the time I was on the show
you get to know someone really well and
I can tell you that I don't really know
much about what he liked on Instagram
but I can tell you from my standpoint
that guy's like a very kind funny goofy
dude kind of like a Jim Carrey type guy
that's just like really really goofy and
funny and just one of those guys like
you if you're gonna be stuck on an
island like he's a solid guy to just
kind of find the positive and everything
so well back I had said many times even
on re-season that she loved a goofball
she loves to be like goofy and fun
that's the definition of a goofball Gary
okay all right interesting well Blake
has seemed very in his head the last few
episodes are we seeing Blake like a
Blake is I think is a very emotional guy
he's an emotional guy
yeah he's very in touch with his
emotions and you know he he's been
through a lot you know and I love that
about him he has a level of depth that's
really beautiful the guy can talk about
anything - so I yeah I love him - we've
got some - two good guys at the end here
okay we have the Bachelorette finale
next week and right after it is going to
be the bachelor in paradise premiere so
I want to wind down here a little
paradise talk because Pierce said we'd
get to your question Pierce said what
did you enjoy more the Bachelorette
experience or the bachelor in paradise
experience who they're so different
that's a difficult thing to really kind
of answer I would say that I have to say
they're about equal for different
reasons but yeah there it was fun both
well we're excited to watch and I was a
little bit surprised we had a bachelor
in paradise promo during mental last
night I want to roll a clip from it
because Leo it really surprised me
I'm not worried about the other guys
because I know I'm falling in love with
Kendall good luck with guts restore over
there how can you be loved with somebody
in your heart just like freaking leo
versus grocery store Joe I mean that
indeed be a good fight you know there'd
be uh does it come town you guys will
have to watch but it you know you told
it's all it was entertaining I'll say
that much I didn't come out of it with
any you know it's it's entertaining and
it was it was still a good experience
over there so you'll have to wait and
see what happens
well Joe was at the men's hell all by
the way I love Joe and he was very sweet
but I think the only guy not wearing a
jacket Joe you got to put a jacket on
jacket but what was it like to see him
at menthol had you spoken since paradise
no we hadn't spoken since paradise but
uh it was fine it was no I don't really
have time for hate you know I guess
we're okay
no nothing uh I would say we're in a
good place
okay did you talk at the taping yeah we
did okay
well what can you tease for us about
what happens between you and Joe and
paradise I would say that it was
emotional you know I think often times
when people have feelings for you know
someone they can be irrational in their
reactions and you know it's it's all
about being human and you know if
everybody's trips to Mexico were taped
I'm pretty sure a lot of people would
have interesting but uh but yeah Joe and
I we were it's it's gonna be good TV
okay do you think Joe's a good guy I
think Joe's a good guy and do you have
any regrets or wish you've done anything
different in Paradise then nope
all right Epis own it okay well we are
excited to see that you know when
people's emotions get involved some
drama can't happen that's the name of
the game that's what happens and I mean
it seems from that trail that it comes
down to miss Kendall yeah yes maybe
we saw her clutching at your beard yeah
yeah yeah that was fun yeah it was yeah
it was it was great
paradise was enlightening in terms of
how you feel about yourself right you
feel about other people or what
everything okay yeah well an
enlightening experience all right you
guys we are winding down here at leo
thank you so much for being here thank
you - pleasure oh it is such a pleasure
I'm so glad we had not met all season
leo
you guys is on instagrams on Twitter
follow him very on snapchat no he's not
on snapchat we're over it we've insta
stories now it would seem I'm just
kidding
so Leo thank you for being here and
everybody Bachelorette finale is next
week bachelor in paradise is beginning
so bachelor nation the ball just keeps
on rolling and we will have a brand new
roses and rows a recap up soon for you
guys thank you so much for watching and
everybody have a great day
[Music]